[Music]
in blank news thank you thank you
submitted by blinker request
by blanker that's pretty much how it got
at the end there it's like you have to
just make this [ __ ] up eventually yeah
all right in conor mcgregor news
i know you like honor i do not anymore
uh yeah i do i'm still fantastic
do you feel like conor mcgregor lost his
edge because he's so rich now he doesn't
care if he wins or lose because he's got
his yachts he just wants to sell whiskey
now yeah he he's too successful to be a
fighter right there like very very well
he's very the rock almost on it right
he's like going in that trajectory but
it's also like dude he's he's doing a
lot of alcohol he's doing a lot of coke
this [ __ ] every video so he's
living it up he's coked up and he's
probably has great business ideas well
in conor mcgregor news he lands his
first
acting role alongside jake gyllenhaal
wow
road house what's that no it's oh yeah
they were doing a movie called october
sky 2.
it is roadhouse
what role does he have is it actually a
roadhouse or yeah yeah it's a
reimagining of the beloved classic
i don't know about that great movie it
is so great for swayze movies to not be
touched i don't yeah that's a [ __ ]
good movie just make a [ __ ] new movie
man so the film marks a new step in the
ufc fighter's career and while the
details of his character remain unknown
jake takes on the role of a former ufc
fighter turned bouncer in the new film
so we take it that connor's fighting
spirit will come uh very very handy in
the second it'll be funny is if he he
just gets cast to to be the guy that
goes i used to [ __ ] guys like you in
prison yeah yeah but with irish accents
just that movement
so amazon studios announced the film on
twitter saying fight icon conor mcgregor
expands his storied career into film to
join jake gyllenhaal in the reimagining
of the beloved classic roadhouse if they
still have the bigfoot scene i'm all in
directed by doug lehmann the film will
be an amazon original released to 240
countries and territories on prime video
sort of straight to prime video it's
already feeling sad
why is that every time i see the prime
logo i'm always like oh no i don't know
the one that i liked was
the new remake
[Music]
so good no
no you have to go with that you have to
go with that
because i remember when that came out it
was the one with brandy no no that one's
very good that's actually way better
than the [ __ ] pizza [ __ ] thank you i
saw that as a kid no the only one i i
watched was man in a high castle that
was sick
oh the show the show yeah you liked it i
liked it well i like the world and the
concept and everything yeah that is a
cool concept yeah it was like um it's
like it's like an alternate world where
in world war ii nazi oh yeah
and then the the us is split into oh
that's too long that's interesting yeah
yeah it's a really and then there's like
one territory in the middle that's kind
of like the uh uh
i guess the like the buffer zone yeah
no it's like it's like the no man's land
oh it's kind of like the mad max area
fans america and nazi america wow that's
cool and then in this plate in the in
the in the the man in the high castle
he has these films and [ __ ] and like it
gets leaked but it's about an alternate
world our world where uh the the u.s won
the war
and that [ __ ] gets passed around and
[ __ ] and it starts [ __ ] with people's
heads and like and they're like freedom
fighters get a hold of it that's cool
yeah it's a really dope concept cool
concept yeah all right but i really like
that and that was the only thing i
watched prime for other than that like i
just buy things on prime you do you know
i hear i hear the boys is good boys is
good oh yeah i've heard
i've seen the boys number one thing i'm
excited about for prime videos the lord
of the rings prequel
that's nerdy that's coming out on prime
it's on it's on prime it's coming out in
like september it's [ __ ] when is
anybody here lord of the rings yeah i
like lord of the rings i think it sucks
yeah only for prime you don't like the
talking tree i think it absolutely sucks
so wait you think
do you think once you lose your
virginity
you no longer like lord of the rings
yeah true dude
hey when i lost my virginity yeah you
got me tripped up sure you lost still
fired up right now dude
i still like lord of the rings so you
stayed
you stayed version you stayed loyal to
your virgin nick nick has had sex with
one woman who just tricks him every
night he doesn't even know what sex is
she's way older than me too
it's gonna be too many capes
you gotta have capes in the earth i
don't like all the cloaks and all the
[ __ ] capes when you're traveling that
long you need a [ __ ] cape why they're
definitely more cloaks than
it pricks you from the sun that's what
it does yeah for sure is that actually
worth no but they have the elven cloaks
that like look like rocks and [ __ ] when
you're hiding they're very very good
they're actually all of them i only
remember the end of the first one where
they get with the elves and [ __ ] they
look out into the scene that small
little piece of that that portion of the
movie is my only memory of all of them i
think you're making that up you also you
also only watch movies once each
but that was like [ __ ] 18 years old
or something yeah
i don't think you have the attention
span to watch a lord of the rings
let alone a trilogy i do remember saying
this movie is so long
it is very long
at the end of it i'm like why are these
[ __ ] elves [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
ears like man why is it so long but it's
whatever it is it is one of those movies
that if you're watching it and you like
get distracted for a little bit you come
back and you just don't enjoy it like
you have to like really live in the
world you got to really like fantasy i
want i gave it a chance i watched all of
them dudes what about like game
what about like gamers i remember the
war the big [ __ ] war
joe
[Laughter]
it was a war best remember there was a
wall like there's always there's a sword
in it there's a [ __ ] sword
do you remember watch there is
remember lords too
[ __ ] elves they got these ear things
what about sneakers what is that about
oh that's the same movie
so that's what this is what 80d does to
your brain when you're watching
something
oh i like that movie okay so you do like
lord of the rings i was thinking about
how you are a virgin
yeah welcome back to virginity yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we missed you
hobbit was even more whack yeah yeah for
sure hobbit was a really good book
though i've heard that
dude you know what i will say though i
wasn't super into lord of the rings
because
growing up and playing rpgs so [ __ ]
much
you're so used to that and everyone
around you acting like it's this new
like you know because a lot of people
weren't at that nerdy until lord of the
rings totally and then they're all
telling you like oh my god the adventure
and the elements and the characters and
you're like dude that's [ __ ] every
game like one of the rings
okay you say yeah yeah are you a virgin
are you a virgin
awesome thank you all right i guess yeah
i guess some people
some people who are
who have had sex before told you also
like hey
that's a case study right there right in
your freaking faces i was wrong the
delivery guy likes lord of the rings and
he has had sex before he says he crushes
it that's what he said that's what you
just said whoever's account that just
got ordered through that's going to get
a little review now so what movie did i
watch
the lord of the weed rings is
and then they're like my precious and
then i remember that
what's the other movie where there was a
[ __ ] at the end there's like a
there's a [ __ ] like elven [ __ ] and
then there's like the [ __ ] good
looking guys and then those the [ __ ]
ugly guys and they're like looking off
into the [ __ ] doors a lot of looking
off in the distance yeah yeah yeah yeah
looking after this
just another the third one maybe okay so
i think maybe at the end of the first
one it's just the hobbits looking off
into mordor not very peaceful distance
they're like looking off into like
destruction and doom
what's the one where they were going to
gay kiss for sure 100 percent that's
always all three
frodo sam
sam and frodo [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely
canon like gay they're supposed to be
gay wow they just get really close but
sam is a [ __ ] though cause every time
he was like mr frodo's mr frodo's i'm
like
shut up [ __ ] you're a fan now
you're right now it's all going back
he's coming back yeah yeah yeah he's the
[ __ ] thing he's got like the
that's what i gotta confuse with
[Laughter]
about narnia stuff yeah bro i got it i
got it [ __ ] up with narnia all right
[ __ ] lord of the rings
and then you remember the the my my
all-time favorite is the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] the when they go through the
closet
that's narnia the lion the witch in the
wardrobe all right
joey's a big movie buff
and a huge fan of film playing the lion
that's the new game because when santa
claus hooks them up with all the weapons
remember that [ __ ] santa claus yes oh
and jingle all the way
is that reindeer games
not like flick charlie's thing joe to
describe movies he's watched in the past
and then we all try to guess yeah that's
the new that's the new jk park right now
and we're gonna pass no but like when
jungle cruise that moment when they when
santa claus gives them all like
different weapons yes like [ __ ] gets
the arrows yeah yeah [ __ ] gets arrows
who's the [ __ ] okay here you go that
[ __ ] over there
you know and then like i was like dude
that's sick and then that one kid gets
that weak ass one i forgot what it was
but it was like it was like
[ __ ] stupid you know i like how joe
always dreamed of making a movie but
he's never sat through a whole movie
he's like movies oh i never watched i
never watched the whole one one watch
per movie too yeah i do like watch his
first 15 minutes at a time
yo i watched some movies on the plane
coming here so what was the movie you
watched i watched the app
the outfit is sick
okay um it's about i wouldn't have
guessed it's about a tailor
uh a person who makes clothes from
england right wonderful story and he's
involved with the mob because the mafia
comes in and they have to drop off uh
like little letters and [ __ ] but i don't
want to spoil it because it's a murder
mystery i'll get i'll give joe credit
for anything mob related yeah yeah but
then i'm expecting yeah that's like
joe's literally being in joe's pov he's
like and then the mobster's wife well
first there's a baby crying and then i
and then somebody asks if you want some
water
it's all real world things
it puts all the swirls all together joe
doesn't know how to compartmentalize my
mouth comes in i had to fasten my seat
belt
and then they started serving did you
know chicken katsu was in the movie
which is [ __ ] dope i flew to united
and they gave me chicken curry katsu
that's dope that was one of the options
appropriating from where to where only
you why oh that makes sense they gave
everyone else they're like would you
like they're like would you like a tofu
something something or would you like
chicken katsu and i'm like are you
[ __ ] with me right now
oh you speak english did you say chicken
katsu
imagine
get a load of this [ __ ] speaks english
[Laughter]
get a load of katsu
it's just a joke but you're all enjoying
it
joe when you go off the plane did they
give you a lay
huh they gave me a bow they gave you
about i'm just kidding
did they still do that no no no
i want to fly in on a pan am and then
[ __ ] walk outside and then they
[ __ ] put on the leg and on the on
spirit if you're wearing a way they
[ __ ]
so they just they go through your whole
body and take it back
can you please lift your leg thank you
they just do the motion they just hula
hoop you
you